So what's the difference between management
and leadership?
Management is the manipulation of others for
personal gain.
Think about the people who we felt
managed by.
Nobody wants to wake up in the morning to
be managed.
We want to wake up in the morning to be led.
Leadership is the responsibility,
the awesome
responsibility to see those around us rise.
It's a different skill set entirely.
We're not being driven by
how to use others so that we can get stuff.
We try to see ourselves, how we can use ourselves,
to help others rise.
That's what leadership is.
It's much harder than management and it takes
a lot more work and a lot more studying,
which is why leadership really is a hard skill and
great leaders really, really, really
work at it.